[Music]
we're in the sports book at Caesar's
Palace as we wait on Kelly and cabby to
get here I have a better with me today
it's a beautiful Sunday in Vegas and I
would like to know who you betting on in
today's and it bill matchups well I like
the Eagles but they're giving up a point
and a half to Seattle Seattle's got the
best quarterback in the league so I'm
kind of mystified with the line here oh
whoa whoa whoa Seattle has the best
quarterback in the league
what about Lamar Jackson well yeah okay
I like Lamar but I don't know what to do
you know
alright those fan but you know give it
up there get given up a point and a half
at home against Seattle Seattle is great
Eagles that happen to know so so season
I think a lot of injuries so I'll make
that decision in a minute or two but my
bets gonna be hurt okay so if you had an
idea and I don't mean to be rude I don't
mean to intrude you're gonna make it
this is on a bit am I allowed to ask how
much you're gonna put on your beloved
Eagles I'll probably put 100 bucks again
okay now just to have some action okay I
like it hundred bucks
safe bet you know whether you win or
lose you know wife won't be mad yeah now
we'll make it home thank you for saying
that yes sir
[Music]
go to you
[Music]
at 22 she was writing a business plan
for a video delivery series called get
flicks its 22 unthreading poetry for
women who had no time for me and at 22
Lamar Jackson is leading the NFL MVP
debate which is crazy this is the PR
betting show presented by the Caesars
Palace sports book she is our betting
insider Kelly Taylor Swift Stewart and
I'm captain pictured cabbie I had a
rough one last week like the Houston
Texans not getting the cover on Thursday
night not it's got a shake that one off
my best bets still 8 2 and 1 on the
season you mention Lamar Jackson who's
been absolutely incredible this season
bring it to the Ravens in this week's
marquee matchups let's go
[Music]
alright let's kick off the marquee
matchups of the week we have the
Patriots plus five and a half total
forty four and a half
I like this Patriots team here listen
Tom Brady the reverse lineman coming in
on this so the reverse lineman coming in
on this game is interesting because I
like the Patriots here but the Patriots
number one defense in the NFL you have
to back this team here I know a lot of
people like the Cowboys but that's not
it
next game up all right guys we have the
Ravens
minus three at the Rams Monday night
Rams total forty six and a half here
Ravens look good only laying three here
should tell you something LA has out
gained all but one of their opponents
currently in the number seven seed on
the outside the playoffs looking in you
have to back the Rams here
next up the Packers plus three at the
49ers total forty seven and a half this
game got West in the prime time to
battle the two first-place teams jogging
for playoff seeding and if you want to
know my best bet on this game you're
gonna have to wait to the end of the
show let's quickly recap the marquee now
if you week I like the Patriots in the
Rams and again you guys gonna have to
stick around for my pick in the Packers
Niners game Kelly over there teasing us
like her high school prom date it's one
of the many things 10 Things I Hate
About You because the audience just
wants your best bet
super bad and we can't hardly wait with
a nod to head coach Nick nurse of the
Toronto Raptors I'm going to exercise
some load management we have a very
special guest who's going to carry us
through expert analysis
[Music]
this is Chad Johnson and I'm here with
Alan iceberg the senior odds maker has
Caesar sports Allen every week the MVP
discussion changes right now my guy
Lamar Jackson is the betting odd favor
to an NFL MVP at this point in the
season which player offers the best
value free NFL MVP I think Pat mahomes
at ten to one is still a possibility you
know he could just start throwing these
Warner games and he'd get right back and
meet his eyes also doc Prescott it ten
to one I think with the Cowboys if
they're able to maybe win Sunday that
road win at Foxborough and the numbers
are good his numbers have been strong
all season I think he could really get
into things especially with the Eagles
falling back to the NFC East
I mean if dak is able to put up good
numbers against that pagers defense he
definitely deserves recognition Pat
mahomes the fact that people really took
him out the race because he was injured
for a game or two is crazy I'm an
emotional guy who won and and right now
what I'm about to talk about this next
prop bet hurts my feelings as a member
of the bangles family
we're sitting on tin and you're Caesar's
Palace has Cincinnati ad plus 425 to
finish the season winless how is that
possible
do you think is gonna happen I don't I
think they're gonna win a game
I definitely think they're gonna look
yeah it's really hard to go all-in 16
yeah I don't see the bank we're not that
bad nah the Bengals are gonna win the
rest of the games a season I wasn't
supposed to say it
okay that's breaking news here for mojo
I got one more question for you
all right if I were to come out of
retirement and play right now what kind
of props would you sit on my performance
this is the thing if I were to come back
I would play two positions not only way
I'd be a receiver but I also be the
kicker Oh the kicker to me all right
oh yeah let's see I'm gonna say eight
and a half touchdowns you still the man
yeah the man you missed only one kickoff
season okay how's that I'm with you
Thank You Allen iceberg rejoin me on
expert analysis I appreciate
yes Alan thank you again for joining us
he delivers great information and
insight on Twitter find him at percent
Berg chat the Bengals are winless this
season my dear how are they supposed to
win out they're gonna win out they're
gonna want out you're going to be a
shootout against the Patriots this piece
it's a toss-up who's gonna win when they
do play but the bangles gonna win the
rest of their games mark my words if it
doesn't happen I'll delete Twitter and
the rest of my social media for week 12
Steelers minus six and a half at the
bangles total 37 this line is dropping
and that should tell you something this
is gonna be a low-scoring game so you
want to gobble up those points why
because this is a situational sandwich
play the Steelers just played their
arch-rivals the Bengals last Thursday
night we saw how that one and then gets
who they have on deck in a weird
scheduling spot that's right the
Cleveland Browns they have no Pouncy
today I like the Bengals plus six and a
half Raiders - three and a half at the
Jets total 45 and a half this Raiders
team stock is high and it's an
interesting sharps and squares are on
the same side in this one but not me I'm
on the Jets I'm alone on an island
because Oakland three and eight against
a spread in their last 11 road games the
Justin played well as of late especially
the last couple weeks I'm riding with
their own momentum with the New York
Jets plus three and a half Jameis
Winston I don't know what I'm gonna do
with this man and we have such a
love-hate relationship and this might be
the end Chad said that if the Bengals
don't win are you can delete Twitter and
- but still win this game I'm gonna have
to delete Twitter bucks plus three and a
half at the Falcons this total sky high
for a reason
listen the Bucs are this Jekyll and Hyde
team but Atlanta should not be laying
points to anyone
Atlanta oh and 7 as a favorite with the
losing records when coming off
back-to-back consecutive wins as a dog
+2 and 12 against the spread at home
after beating Carolina I like the Bucks
plus 3 and a half that is my card for
week 12 cabbie well your love-hate
relationship is more hate hate
relationship with Genesis there are some
questions that even I'm too embarrassed
to ask so I just wait for someone on
social tasks it's awesome for me the
from the minds of the public I am in
Joshua says Seahawks moneyline seems
like a sure thing is it Kelly you know
since we had this question asked this
line has gone absolutely wild Eagles was
- - now Seahawks are headed to - before
kick so I understand what he was asking
initially because Russell Wilson as an
underdog always looks tempting but you
guys cannot back this defense on the
road bottom line I can't even name any
of the Eagles receivers outside of
Matthews isn't that fat we give this
entire depth chart and everybody's hurt
I still like the Eagles here think that
Seahawks overreaction to the injuries is
just a little too much shout-out to your
boy Nelson a galore Gibbs 72s why don't
you just pick a top vet and then have
that one with your bankroll you know I
get this a lot right and give them eight
- and one of my best bets here on the
show so why not just bet my best bet
every week well there's a couple of
reasons to it one I like the action and
you know who doesn't want to have a ton
of game but also because you have to
practice a good bankroll management so
it's better to sprinkle it around and
have a few games that you really like
instead of just laying it all on one
game you really love I think we're all
action junkies teller that's what we're
watching the show enjoy the show don't
bet as she says don't bet your entire
bankroll on one game so you can sprint a
little round others other games that
you're confident in with that said we've
come to the part of the show where her
confidence shines like shiny new armor
on the mandalorian Kelly give the people
your best bet I'm really sad today
because our two-month unbeaten streak
ended last week when Nelson al Ghul or
didn't catch that touchdown pass in the
end zone and the Phillies Philadelphia
failed to cover against New England but
unlike the Eagles my best bets are still
flying high 8 2 and 1 on the season this
week's best bet is the 49ers - 3 do not
buy the hype with Green Bay that defense
is not as good as we once thought you
know what she thinks is good the 49ers
outside of that Dallas win who with
Green Bay beaten on the road and no
Kansas City was out mahomes does not
count it looks like we're gonna have
George kiddo back which is exciting but
it doesn't matter because last week 10
different players caught passes from my
man Jimmy G we're in a rock with the
49ers - three
let's recap all of my picks for reads 12
these oh it's an order of confidence on
how many units I'd recommend you bet on
each I've got two for you to play on the
49ers three unit play on the Rams
bangles and Eagles remember a unit is a
standard venom out to be about 1% of
your bankroll I've also got two unit
plays on the Patriots buck and the Jets
fo the injuries on the 49ers is Kelly
and loaded - are you gonna jump on a
flight after the show
fly to San Francisco and suit up for the
Niners tonight definitely not there's
nothing I can do - for the 49ers right
now except be the waterboy that's not
true I think you can kick fill both cuz
Robbie Gold's hurt you know what we can
make that happen
okay to work out 49ers calling me I'm
available thank you for streaming the VR
buddy show presented by the Caesars
Palace sports book whether you like to
fade or fall you can find all my pics on
social advocates we're betting
thank you mr. Johnson you and good luck
on all your bets today here's to a
profitable Sunday
kiss me tonight solos chippendale act
thank you
[Music]